sonic remote controls linear algebraic
simulation thanks to the organizers for
the invitation and all of you for coming
to the stops late in the day yeah so the
stock is part of a survey of this
emerging area calls which I called
linear algebraic pseudo randomness and
it covers a bunch of works which you
have been doing in the past few years
I've mentioned the search takes things
later on but it's a variety you know
several people so roughly speaking the
subject aims to understand linear
algebraic analogs of various fundamental
bhuiyan fool around objects in the
boolean would you know you could take
extracts versus expanders error
correcting codes all those things and
where you replace the size of the subset
by the lines of subspaces and you kind
of think about Daniel Nava's questions
in the linear algebraic world you get a
variety of interesting objects so some
examples are codes in the rank metric
expansion and dimension sex with deviate
subspaces things which preserve linear
maps which preserve rank and the main
topic of the talk perhaps your subspace
design and why we are interested in this
is twofold one is that these things are
interesting for their own sake for
ignorant interest plus they also have a
variety of applications to the diverse
settings so we can construct ramps a
graph build a lisp equal double code
they're useful for polynomial identity
testing and this will also come up in
Michael folks talk tomorrow morning and
variety of coding applications as well
okay so so this talk is about two main
objects one is dimension expander which
I'm going to define now and this summer
was was put forth in a unpublished work
by Barack compania so spiritual carving
person both for me as bad as a linear
algebraic and a lot of vertex expansion
in class okay so what's the definition
so you pick some vector space over
finite fields X to the N or it can be
any field but mostly think of finite
fields for the stock and you're going to
have a collection of D linear maps from
F together
and you say that this is the become
alpha dimension expanded the following
happens if you take any low dimensional
subspace of F to the end of dimension at
most be and the astronauts with all his
math a 1 280 and the sum of that so some
of those subspaces has dimension which
is noticeably bigger than the dimension
of B so it's at least 1 plus alpha times
we ok so the definition clear so we can
always take a a 1 equals identity you
will have alpha equals 0 / the idea is
to have a few more maps which will
expand every subspace and these called
the degree of the dimension expander
seduce the parallel with vertex X you
know graphics pandals expand the rat and
alpha is the expansion factor sometimes
you can call 1 plus alpha the expansion
factor but since the expansion of one is
trivial let me call alpha the expansion
factor you just apply the linear math to
the vector space upstairs me you get
another subspace sorry so just some the
subspace some of subscription you're a
junior union brake adjuster yeah we
should your substrate you contain to you
also stages until we make it so and that
should be at least 1 plus alpha 10
student and you can see the parallel
with this being neighborhood maps and
the size of the set on the left for
small steps have been at least 1 plus
alpha times bigger ok that's the
parallel so it should again this is the
definition succinctly and again this as
always in pseudo randomness when
confronted with something like this you
try a random construction and random
objects are pretty good so just sample
parameters not try it or anything but if
you take collection of 10 random map
over any field that will expand sets of
dimension of 10 / 2 by let's say if you
know 1 alpha will be half go by a factor
of P half probably yeah I just wanted to
be safe and put some tension
maybe even two would work yeah yeah i'm
not sure but but maybe if you change the
n over 2 to say no or 10 maybe two would
work do anything maybe some trade off
okay but crudely let's think of the
following two so this is one setting
where you have one Omega n sighs
diamonds dimension sets to expand and
you care about the degree being some
absolute constant you don't care what
this the other thing you can ask is that
suppose I pick D linear maps you can
hope for the dimension to be close to D
and you can also achieve that and for
sex of course of dimension pay less than
n over 2 D so both of these are true and
of course the the challenge is to come
close to these sorts of results with
explicit construction and sort of a good
ballpark is this goal which is that you
want constant degree dimension expanders
which expand by a constant factor Omega
n dimension to linear spice linear
dimension set should expand by contract
ok so that's a challenge ok so I'll
leave it at that will come back for
dimension expanded but now let's talk
about something called subspace designs
and we'll connect it to Dimension X
family ok like sand against my thumb
impression good question I don't know so
there is a construction of so in some
sense for example this challenge is met
over fields of characteristic 0 and that
indeed is based I mean the way it is
done it also implies vertex etext vertex
expanders and built these things but I
don't know if there's a black box
connection
okay I'll have to think about this okay
so slight lift in topics up space design
okay so the way I will talk about this
part of the talk which is sort of the
bulk of the talk is I'll say why we
define these subscales designs the
motivation came from coding tail and
then I give the definition and then I'll
talk about a construction and then the
last part we'll talk about applications
broader applications in linear algebra
to the randomness in particular how they
relate to dimension expansion ok ok so
the motivation for sub square design was
to reduce the output list size in
certain list error correction algorithms
for variants of reed-solomon algebra
geometry code so there are various
algebra course for which you have less
decoding algorithms and these were
useful to reduce than this size so let
me say I don't want to get too much
interest into this connection but I at
least even I was trying to show how this
actually at all so what are we Solomon
codes so these are a very well-known
code which takes polynomials of degree
less than K and map it to their
evaluations as a number of points which
exceeds their degree so you get
redundancy so you take a degree K minus
1 polynomial evaluated at in places you
get this and easy property of this is
that because degree K minus 1 polynomial
has at most K minus 1 roots any to such
in codings will be quite far from each
other they'll differ in at least n minus
k plus 1 places which means if you take
one code word and correct it in n minus
K by 2 positions we can still go back to
the original message or code word any
unambiguously and you can also do this
efficiently using a variety of cells or
something this has been known for a long
time so we're list decoding comes up is
you try to correct a number of errors
which exceeds this bump in which case
you cannot always hope to get a unique
answer but you resort to what's called
is decoding very all put all the answers
which are consistent with that many
errors having occurred ok so that's the
problem and so for reed-solomon codes
you can let's decode them up to a number
of errors which always exceed is n minus
K by 2 but it turns out these are not as
good as what one can hope for for
example if you take random code if you
take random force over to sufficiently
big alphabet they will allow decoding up
to a number of errors
which is almost n minus K so which is
two times bigger and that's clearly the
limit you can go far and so it's a nice
question so natural question is can you
do that with the end reed-solomon codes
quite don't quite achieve that but there
are those we know many explicit by now
some explicit course which achieve this
and these are twists on reed-solomon
code so it started with work with three
[ __ ] where we had folded reed-solomon
codes but now by now there are many
other course and other variants which
also achieve and the couple of those
explicit constructions is what motivated
subspace device get so let me give a
little more detail there so what we did
for that is but reed-solomon codes
itself in general we do not know how to
go beyond this the N minus quadrant k
and bound but here is a reasonable quote
with a crisp when I take polynomials
with coefficients in a big field in
extension field but i only use elements
in the base field as evaluation ok so
the key thing here is the wreck the a
ice could come from fqdn but i don't do
that i only use things in it fq ok why
do we do this it does go for this and i
won't give any details of this but for
this with shopping jing we could give a
list according a little bit the
following kind of guarantees a bit of a
mouthful but the two important things
are in red there so it sends click on
any parameter s which is of your choice
and if you take s equals one will be
back to an ambiguity coding but if we
take larger s you improve the fraction
number of errors you correct so as is
growth you get better and better number
of errors but what you promised becomes
weaker and weaker then what you promise
is that you will pin down all possible
polynomials which could have been sent
to a subspace and that subspace will
have the following kind of structure
various coefficients of that polynomial
will belong to a fine ship of a fixed
low dimensional subspace so which each
of these coefficients must be roughly
speaking in a lower dimensional subspace
and that subspace will be the same
across all the coordinates ok I'm not
going to tell you why we can get this
but this is something we could prove
and this of course means that the number
of they can compute the dimension of the
subspace for each position there are s
minus one dimension there are K position
so the number of solutions is something
like this but that's too big even if you
take s equals to this is like you to the
case that's exponentially cycle we take
x equals one you get back your old
algorithm but for s equal to and beyond
you are doing something non trivial but
it's not the list is still very big so
we would like to bring down this this
site and that's where subspace divine
kill you so just you think you recover
open and look you know so you say you
somewhere so you packed more errors and
whatever received word you get the
theorem says that all the code words you
need to output will belong to the
subspace I'm not saying all of them will
be close by but everything closed i will
be in the sub and then i suppose you can
go ahead and pull that subspace but the
problem is aspect it's too big so you
cannot do this to yourself is to be
richer so it's a samosas you can pin
down the possible solution through a
very structured subspace and software
designs are going to help to go further
than that so what are those things and
again don't it's not too important on
the Strand listing so please idea with
subspace designs is that once you have
this subset design with this we will do
a precoding step that will say that
instead of diet coefficient being an
arbitrary field element it should belong
to some subspace hm ok so there's
something we will design doing the code
design H eyes are part of the horse
specification and now it's easy to see
that if you have these linear systems
plus the fact that if I belongs to H I
the total space was possible solutions
now becomes knots s minus 1 times K but
it's simply the sum of the dimension of
the intersection because roughly
speaking a nice step you must belong to
W don't worry about the defined ships
that works up it must belong to W but
you also know you always belong to each
other so you must belong to it w
intersect H I you sum that up overall
position that's your total damage and is
going to be to pay that you would in so
this place is small
our this dimension is small so that your
overall space is low dimensional and you
can output wall should be a constant yes
exactly because the number of solutions
will be Q to this dimension Q is like n
for each Solomon codes do you want this
to be pleased so you want to concern a
child so this is true for every w yeah
we are even w no no so it should be you
don't splice control w other than the
fact that it's low dimensional so I will
define success design for the next slide
it will be for all so sir idea is that
you'll insist you pick an H I Specter
collection array sites as a fuel this is
guaranteed to be small no matter what W
is of course you can clearly do that by
taking a chai to be time but you don't
want to do that you want to keep the
rate high so the H I should be very
high-dimensional so they should have
dimension almost ok so it should be 1
minus epsilon times n so that the hit
you Ray take in the rate is pretty small
so what is the meaning HR is like the
space which simple yes there are
different should I apportion should come
from a subspace HR right there is one
for each book so the rate will be some
of the dimension right so you each each
position you lose a pack of 1 minus
epsilon so the overall loss in rate is
factor 1 minus 7 ok so that's the ok
even if this connection was a little bit
fuzzy go ok worry about is it just to
say that they come up in a very natural
way with this algorithm that's all we do
that's why we define them but later the
definition ok so definition of subspace
designs is the following so you fix a
vector space SQ to the m earlier i had
the extension field but let's think of
with an isomorphism it has a vector
space of length dimension M so you want
a collection of subspaces of this space
and you want all of them to have high
dimension or local dimensions you call
it to be an extra mile software design
if for every f dimensional subspace W of
SQ to the M this totally intersection is
a smoother ok I'll s minus 1 in the
previous slide but we just make it s
ok select and then it and obviously you
would like this L to be small and you
would like to have a large collection of
subspace ok so you'd like a large
collection of subspaces which have low
intersection now one point is that this
might look a bit cumbersome but the
point is this also implies that if you
take any any W the number of HIV even
mantra will intersect w is tiny it has
to be at most n or this and that
property is something which we call a
week subspace design and this is a
strong subspace design or just subscribe
to them can this distinction is a little
bit important but for intuition you can
just think about this this way you have
a collection of subspaces such that any
lower dimensional subspace this only
intersect a very small number okay we
are gonna exploit a bit on what to call
this in some or call it subspace design
for exactly a design innocence okay so
the definition place
but once again so pseudo random object
what can you do Speedy's at random so
again our epsilon M will be the poor
dimension let's fix a finite field FQ
then if you pick a random collection of
about 2 to the epsilon M sub spaces
that's quite a lot of subspaces you
Italy can prove that that will be an s
comma L sub space design where L is only
like s over epsilon okay so it s is a
constant then this will also be a
constant as revolution for the
replication is important that n is
baseball so even though you have a lost
a lot of subspaces for any X dimensional
subspace only about s over epsilon will
intersect plus it's a strong substances
in property and this is roughly the
right ballpark because of course s is a
lower bound on L because you can take W
to be contained inside h1 and then the
dimension of W intersect h1 is f we
can't do better than that and it's not
hard to see 1 over epsilon is also a
lower bound because each of these
subspaces is co dimension epsilon m so
you can basically take w which
intersects the first one over epsilon of
the reach of them is epsilon m linear
constraints we can keep from so roughly
this is more or less the best I mean I
don't know if this is formally a lower
bound x over epsilon is dr.
I think they actually paper which proved
but nice no not in this context but s
plus 1 over epsilon is a lower bound and
the other night and again if you plug it
in this in the application we just said
it is thrown out that you can correct a
number of errors which is 1 minus
epsilon times the best you can hope for
and the dimension of the solution space
and so being huge will now be something
like 1 over epsilon squared it only
depends on yeah everything is linear
algebra once you compute this a choice
there's algorithms linear algebraic it
will tell you w everything is just
falling linear foot okay but apples
you're right that this but to consider
the power you need the data is
explicitly so the big challenge in this
to get explicit course was to find such
great designs with parameters close to
this in an explicit man okay so that's
the challenge
also those whispers what's the capacity
we got a collection which is more or
less as good as the probability
construction so they got an explicit
construction which is an Eskimo to sm
epsilon sub space design everything more
or less the same as the previous line
the number of subspaces we got was a
little bit lesser it's not cuter epsilon
m but epsilon and bias but that's not
that wasn't so critical the the bad
thing is this theorem is that we add
this thing in Z so this only worked so
the construction only works for large
feet so the problem Sigma third in
something doesn't care about the field
looks for any finite field this is only
works for large beat okay so this is an
explicit construction i'll tell you a
little bit about this construction we
can also get something over small fields
by just walking or an extension field
and simply mapping elements in the
extension field two vectors or the base
field this that's work or every field
with one important caveat it takes the
subspace design upstairs in the big
field but it makes it a week subspace
design some or it doesn't preserve the
intersection I mentioned and this is the
nuisance it is so so we can also get
this for every field with the week
property and again these results have
been used to give explicit cores of
optimal read and then p for less
decoding in a variety of settings both
for constant size alphabets and in the
rank metric and so on and for these
application some of this week property
was not such a big deal I it was
important to get a lot of subspaces the
week was a strong was not so crucial
please decoding your thing is work yeah
it was funny it is will be better it
will give slightly better parameters if
it were strong but the decode not okay
on the other hand great questions
the other hand the application i want to
highlight at the end of the top two
dimension expanders for that the
strongness of the subspace design is
actually crucial and for that what can
we do so we have a recent result with
shopping Shing and Shen yuan where the
so turns out i'll show you the
construction in the previous slide
that's based on polynomials and it was
not quite obvious how to extend it to
work with more general functions but now
we can have a construction based on
cyclotomic function field which more or
less gets you the same thing as the
previous slide but this sor epsilon and
now there is no restriction on the field
size but that intersection bound into
the rest over epsilon is basically s log
in by epsilon so you have to pick up an
extra logarithmic factor unfortunately
and that turns out to if this was not
there we would get constant degree
dimension expanders but because of this
now we get larger to mystically
Dimension X well come to that path lead
so one of the right open question is
somehow to get the clean pipe results
for all fields without any caveats
that's still open and in fact need for
the dimension of expansion application
you don't even have to have epsilon very
small you can take epsilon to be half so
even if you get a collection of em over
two dimensional sub spaces in FM and you
don't even need too many of them as long
as you don't pay an extra price here we
go say that's a good open from yeah
pretty much any little Omega one is this
all so much easier / characteristic 0 is
this our soup doesn't seem too I mean
the proof I show you with polynomials
doesn't seem to care yeah but the
dimension expansion question is easier
or character
any questions so now I'll get to the
sort of maybe the technical part a
little bit where I and say what this
construction is so the way we so I won't
talk anything about this improved
construction because this is it gets
into algebraic function fields and so on
but this earliest construction I have
written it in a slightly different one
not so there are sooo of parameters here
so you already saw s and m and Q but now
there is only two more parameters r and
t so we can get a collection of
subspaces of four dimension RT and it
gives you a subspace design which has
this sort of form don't worry about it
too much i'm going to simplify this in a
second and unbasic alee once you have
this you just stick some parameter takes
T to be 2x and are to be something like
this you get the promise skill okay so
so this is just the wave parameters work
and I'll illustrate they're both 0 is
actually three simplification there is a
parameter are here which gives you a lot
of subspaces let me just make that to be
one and only give you Q sub spaces or at
Q and I won't quite sure the strong
property and only show the week's
property and also as I said this
construction works only over large field
but I won't even show you that I'll only
show the case when the characteristic
itself is large okay all this up ideas
this will be enough to illustrate value
okay
ok so again I'm sort of a mouthful here
with our and all those things but really
the thing I want to talk about here is
this thing so I have a collection in
explicit set subspace design for s
dimensional sub spaces with intersection
bound roughly ms by t minus n ok and
what is te t is the poor dimension of
the substrate so as you decrease the
size of the subspaces I get better and
better intersection bound there and what
else can I say about it yeah and then
this works for characteristic more than
it so this is going to be the idea let's
see this and actually as we see more
spare more at the serum the parameters
will become a little most natural so
let's warm up with a very simple case
when you want a subspace design for one
dimensional sub spaces so s equals 1 and
further I will make tea or so to be one
so now I want the connection of poor
dimension ones are staples such that for
every one dimensional subspace very few
of them intersected again I'm not
worrying about the front property I mean
just doing the deep property what does
it mean for a subspace what is the
one-dimensional subspace it is simply
the multiples of a non zero point so
what we now want is we want a collection
of subspaces such that for any non zero
point in a few trillion and I've
suggestively called that point P that
point should be nice most M minus one of
the subspaces you get the number of
subspaces I should give you is cute
okay and the transaction is going to be
very simple so this is what we do and
really what we're going to do is I
suggestively cause the ski because I
want to think of SQ to the airlines the
space of polynomials of degree n minus 1
so let's do that let's identify this so
now you want a collection of subspaces
that that every nonzero polynomial
belongs to few of them so the only thing
we know about nonzero polynomial of low
degree is that it doesn't have too many
roots so somehow belonging to these
different subspaces should have
something to do with picking up some
good and that's going to guys how we
define the subspace so indeed here is
the collection for every point in FQ you
define the co dimension 1 sub space
because this is one linear condition on
the coefficient of P such that solve
those polynomials which manage it on is
a few subspaces and this property should
be immediately if we take a nonzero
polynomial of degree less than n with a
dash most M minus 1 root and it can only
belong to HR 5 it has root K and this
construction is not new here and this is
called the moment based construction it
has been used in a couple of places
before an explicit place which appears
in the paper of Gabby's on and Rosanna
fine extractors well-known control ok
you solve for T equals 1 and again the
intersection bound is exactly a minus 1
into the SNT when it is plus one or both
or one of those same s equals one let's
go with that that's very simple but now
larger see so now I want a lower code
and higher for dimension subspace but I
want into my intersection bound by a
factor of P
okay it turns out that if you just
stared at this and what we want is
almost a very natural thing to do is
they're going to change the substrate
h-alpha to be all those polynomials
which don't just vanish a transfer but
vanishes multiply at least e Azam Shah
equivalently X minus alpha to the TV
divides p which is a linear which is
teal in your condition okay
and again the proof should be clear if
you have a nonzero polynomial whenever
it belongs to H all six of these groups
at alpha with multiplicity so it can
belong to a chance at most M minus 1
over T back again this car this does the
s equals one case of subspace divine so
this was quite easy and now the more
general case with yes is it easy to see
that the ignition p little boots
efficacy root alpha is peeling a
condition yeah so in this case there are
big characteristics so we can just say I
have written it out this way so maybe
now it's clear because P of alpha is 0 p
prime of alpha is 0 and the t minus 10
meter another way should see this is X
minus alpha to the T devices so you can
divide P by X minus alpha to the T and
then all those coefficients should be V
the t minus 1 the domain there should be
zero that's all other people well which
is equivalent yeah but if you do the
division it's not me how you think of
any real solution here we're into the
coefficient the coefficient there but
there are many businesses Goodman and
you can also do it over small things
would happen elevators so this part
would work but the proofs doesn't work
for small cat so but here yes again
actually that's why I don't read out it
this way as these t minus 1 partial no
derivatives all vanish and I talked to
the same construction it works for nes
and it gives you this bound which is
basically a factor s bigger so let's try
to sketch proof let's finish it up and
does it give some idea okay so the proof
so let's try to prove this pump wolf
idea
so the proof are here is going to be
again by the polynomial method it is a
good example of the use of polynomial
method so what we are going to do is
that suppose there is w of dimension
espoo it is an arbitrator dimensional
subspace and we want to prove that the
number of so to prove w intersect h
alpha is not empty not 0 and four at
most M minus 1 s by t minus s plus 1
values of alpha so these are good okay
just restating what we need to prove so
the wave polynomial method is going to
come map is that for every double so
given such a w we will associate a
polynomial so the W will associate some
polynomial Q W the univariate polynomial
and its degree will be M minus 1 times n
which is the numerator and then and this
will be non 0 q w should be non we go so
essentially we associate a nonzero
polynomial with this and this step of
basically trigger in a one-dimensional
case the one dimension case w itself was
a polynomial is the multiples of a
polynomial this q w is equal to that p
and now we do this and i know we'll just
basically proved that if w intersect a
chance is not trivial that implies Q W
has t minus s plus one room
okay so this is going to be done such so
once you prove this one we have is you
have done because the degree is n minus
1 times s and again okay so this is the
structure and so the key thing is what
is this polynomial Q W so W is going to
give a span of s polynomial okay so
let's say it's prime of X for long is so
Q W is going to be is the what's on the
wrong skin or the determinant of the
wronskian of the sector which is a
fairly natural object so you take this
determinant which p1 x v1 prime X T 1
second derivative p 1 t 1 for yes my
expectation is the clave is column is
simply takes is polynomial and it just
puts in the polynomial its first
derivative the second derivative so this
is the polynomial the determinant is a
polynomial and it's pretty clear it has
degree n minus 1 times s because each of
these polynomials of degree n minus 1 is
an F crossref determinant and the only
facts which are going to use without
proof and it's a very standard facts
from Ueno 19th century and so on and
it's not hard to prove is that if these
are linearly independent polynomials
over X cubed then this wronskian
determinant is actually non z
because of the fact i want full but it
was kind of site basic ensued yeah yeah
yeah
even for the polynomial if you find it
based on the basis right by multiples
like if you want to change the bases
you're doing column operations but the
nurses are linear so your column
operations you're just going to take me
a scalar and s cube so so that's what
you meant by basis the choice is about
yes it doesn't but actually even if it
did for the proof it doesn't matter for
the proof is only important it's nonzero
but the point is any choice of basis
will give the same wronskian up to a
skill as a polynomial yes but so this is
the case when characteristic SQ is more
than the degree of the poem that's where
they and ok all that is good so we have
this polynomial it has low degree so why
does it have these many zeros so maybe
it's late in the day so maybe I'll just
say how it white have so many zeros but
it should be pretty clear it have at
least 10 whenever w intersects HR ok so
let's just see that so the whole matrix
is not 0 so 0 right so what does it mean
is w intersect a charger is not empty
which utilize there exists a linear
combinations right exactly so there is
some linear combination of this
polynomial which has at least t roots at
alpha so if you take the same guinea a
combination of this column put in x
equals also you will get these because
you only go up to s minus 1 derivatives
here and t is a bigger than if i said
that a bit pattern just say that again
so you take this particular polynomial
so this belongs to w intersect h alpha
because w intersects this is a non zero
linear combination now if you take this
linear combination of these polynomials
so take the same linear combination of
these columns and if you put in x equals
alpha right so then you will get 0
I saw or rather this linear combination
of these things yes so if it takes let
me just like this place PJ of alpha 0
summation beta JP JP prime alpha 0 and
so on and so forth and therefore when
you put in x equals alpha this
determinant have spanish because the
corresponding columns the next equals
alpha are linearly dependent it picks up
one but actually there is a slack here
because in h alpha because this guy
belongs to h alpha in fact i can go all
the way up to summation beta SP t minus
1 alpha is 0 but here for this
determinant I only go up to s minus 1 so
there is a bit of flash and that's what
we exploit to get further okay so
without doing the full calculation the
basic argument is very simple we have
this polynomial what do you need to
prove you need to do that if you
differentiate it once that will still
vanish return so this one I just stood
here shows the Q W of alpha is 0 but you
also need to pro QW prime of alpha 0 so
why is this going to be the case well
you take a determinant it's just a ways
you know chain rule operates when I
differentiated determine and something
nice happens it is the sum of s
determinants that is just to
differentiate the first row in the
second one I differentiate the second
row and so on and the point is you will
never talk about a derivative up more
than t minus 1 as long as you
differentiate only t minus s
like let's say advice experimental party
device g one probably
x minus all part of the P divides the
linear combination book so you don't
quite know but can't you do the
determinant after to emulate a
combination not sure but yeah this is
one proof and it's not hard so just
differentiate the determinant t minus s
times you will never get a row which is
more than t minus which talks about any
derivative more than t minus one and all
those things are linearly dependent and
sorry if it is a bit quick but as you
can see there's nothing too fancy going
on once you have the idea to take this
construction and to think about the
wrong key yes what this construction
would mean in character 20 13 days are
indexed by points for the field right
right so this guy this construction boss
probably just works over characteristic
0 right we can actually having fun
countably many subspaces such that 0
yeah so I think it just worked
any other questions about this
okay so now let me briefly mention how
we remove these please simplifications I
mean first things I only give you a few
subspaces maybe I want to pick a lot
more the way you do that is that engine
stopped picking alpha in just a field SQ
you can talk about alpha coming from a
bigger extension field you can do a same
argument told the only difference is now
this is not a dimension for dimension t
subscript but it's a poor dimension are
P sub space because vanishing at a
higher bill point is our linear
condition lowest okay that's more unless
that's all there is to it and you get
you to the r by r sub spaces because it
should avoid if you take things in a
field which is not in any smaller feet
so it's a strong subspace design
property basically it's the same
argument you just have to stare at it
closer and do a more careful analysis
the point is if you w intersects in
eight alphas with a higher dimension
then in some sense this matrix is not
just singular it has its kernel as even
higher dimension in fact the dimension
will exactly be the dimension of this
intersection you can do this argument
more carefully you get okay no no real
change no change the construction just
change to the analysis and the last
point is that we would like to remove
this restriction of large characteristic
and there we just change the
construction so instead of saying that
you vanishes I chose this because it's
maybe more intuitive to think about but
instead of saying it vanishes with
multiplicity at alpha you actually say
that it vanishes at T different points
which are scarcely related so the point
should be alpha alpha times gamma and
alpha times gamma to the t minus once we
take these two points you say you manage
at all these points and that's the four
dimension T sub space and the same proof
more or less goes through you have to
replace the wrong skin by something
which we call the folder ronski we're in
the first place you'll have the P is the
settings that you have p1 of gamma x p2
of gamma X and so on so basically these
are polynomial these are shifted by
powerful come and you can prove the same
theorem that linear independence implies
that determinant is non zero and the
good argument okay so that's how we do
any questions so
okay and these parameters might look
strange but you just picked the correct
value of T and R and so on you get
exactly what I said earlier you can get
a collection of four-dimensional salon
in subspace is that this quantity
becomes x over epsilon and that's okay
any question so in some sense that's the
most the fourth part of the past we've
done the substrate designs I've told you
why we define them gave the definition
and I also told you how to construct
them or large piece I did not say how to
construct well you can do one thing for
small feels as if Eddie can convert
strong to weak by just three encoding
things but I did not pay out to turn
circuit directly or small fields because
that requires not polynomial based
construction but function Creek
Wisconsin but now perhaps in the spirit
of the workshop let's go back to the
broader theme of linear algebraic so the
random ok so here is an alchemist view
of subspace designs which in some sense
was the impetus to this part and and it
arguably actually sub square designs
could have been defined from this
perspective because it has some nice
applications but here is an ultimate
people so we have a collection of
substrate is H I of core dimension
epsilon so we can think of it as the
kernel of a map which maps F to the
Empress to the epsilon so let's the
insert think of the linear map if I'm of
the view where we change subspaces
linear maps and such power here and
actually in our construction the maxi
eyes are very very simple so they
basically took a polynomial and the
linear map was simply evaluated it at a
bunch of points or evaluated it Tori
these derivatives at a bunch of points
depending on which construction you that
is a very nice man and now comes here is
the key are the point of the connection
which is simple just a rank nullity
theorem what the dimension of W
intersect H I it is simply dimension of
the whole space W minus the dimension of
the image eiw if you take this to the
other side it's more apparent it's just
rank nullity theorem so dimension of W
is a dimension of the intersection with
the colonel of the dimension of the
image under na VI so as we arrange them
why do I do this well because of the
following thing so if this dimension is
positive that is equivalent to saying
that II i WS lower dimension then W so
this point is simple but we just do it
carefully so if you have the SLV design
property what does it mean you have a
collection of mass e 1 2 a.m. but for
dimensional subspace all that L of the
mass has to preserve the dimension for
you because whenever they shrink the
dimension you pick up at least one in
the intersection and the sum of the
intersections are of the number of
things intersect is at most n so the
nice thing there for the alternate views
that as soon as your subspace design has
more than else points so for this part
is not too important how big your
collection is as soon as it exceeds n
you have this property once you are more
than love these nuts for any low
dimensional subspace at least one of the
map must preserve the rack ok and this
notion has been implicit in many works I
don't know the history but it certainly
came up in work of separation szpilka
and so on and probably Michael will tell
more about registry and it's connection
so other things like polynomial identity
resting so that's lost less than
contention and I call it lost less
because the dimension is fully preserved
a thing which is maybe somewhat newer in
our work and this game in love with
Michael the Commissioner dimension
expanders is the last version which is
really where we use the strong property
so now what we say is that you take we
canvassed ask how many mass can shrink
the dimension by more than a 1 minus
Delta fact now whenever it shrinks the
dimension this some this intersection
dimension is more than delta x of
dimension and if the sum of those
dimensions is at most else it cannot be
more than delta as whatever the time
with a lower desire and that becomes i
mean it is a very straightforward
reformulation but you see the power of
the scene next couple of slides so there
is a lot of diversion and we're now the
nice thing is that the the size of the
subspace design only needs to be more
than n over del x as soon as it's more
than L over Delta s some mass must
preserve the ranch up to factor 1-10 ok
so this is reformulations why am I
believe during this point it's the
connection to dimension expander ok so
so let's recap what dynamism expanders
was is the first part of the talk so
it's again we have an FF to be n vector
space the collection of the linear map
is that for every be dimensional
subspace when you asked all the maps on
is the dimension goes up by a factor of
1 results
okay and these the degree and alpha is
the expansion pack so now we would like
to construct okay so let's see what the
idea so so what Michael and my dick is
that we said that you would sing the
subspace designs you can construct the
inner sort of a nice black box way and
idea basically to cancer and then
condense so the contents has in the
previous slides so what do I mean by 10
12 it is a very simple operation so the
specific I'll show a very specific
simple instantiation so you want
dimension expansion in X to the N so
what you first do is that you tensor it
with f2 so you basically go to a bigger
space s 2 p.m. and then you condense
back there together so he go to the
bigger space in a some trivial way you
basically say t1 so you take two maps p1
not be is basically d comma 0 and T 2 of
V is 0 comma B so this is two maps and
they give you perfect expansion of
factor of two but of course it's trivial
because your ambient dimension is gone
up by a factor of two it's just not
doing anything interesting but it says
it okay if I have more room to expanding
expansion is pretty dreamy so you did
that you got a factor 2 expansion but
now you have to bring back in ambient
dimension to s to the n without washing
up your expansion completely that you
can lose you know almost half but you
shouldn't lose half the expansion right
so that's the right okay in the final
step you have what you do is that you
now take these maps from a subspace
design for m4 now your ambien dimension
should be 2n so take em equals to n and
you take a subspace design and you don't
even have to have very large dimensional
subspace because the co dimension is
half the total dimension so you take a
collection of em over two dimensional
sub spaces with associated Colonel max e
1 2 a.m. and your final substance design
sorry final dimension expanded will
simply be to compose this map you expand
your dimension using the TI the condoms
/ space back using the ETA and the two
and Max is going to be your setups get
up so explosive [ __ ] this is a very
so once you have so let's just see what
you need from the standards i'm in this
step is trivial so the action will see
in terms of you don't need much and
certainly what you need we can already
provide with the subspace designs we
have okay and suppose the kernels of
these subscripts design forum ESCA
I see a software design let's see some
conflict again the epsilon went away so
it's basically some absolute constancy
suppose we have this and we know that we
can guarantee this by a polynomial bit
construction and what is this little
previous fast I said about the velocity
condensing basically in the setting of
parameters just paste the following as
soon as you have at least three see map
in your substrate design for NES
dimensional subspace at least one of
them we preserve the lack of to a factor
of two Toads so that's idea so you start
with a sub space of dimension x over to
you cancer you make it dimension s so we
go up by factor too but you lose a
factor to third but that's okay the
two-thirds x 2.is process which is still
more than one and therefore just the
composition will give you they say that
dimension x over two subspaces expand by
a factor of four thirds okay [ __ ] in
our language men cancel this month and
that's it and the ranch the degree of
six times so all you needed was like in
a linear map with this property in the
New York edges the connection so I know
this is your parameters here but really
the idea is we can think of the subspace
designs as condensing maps which shrinks
the damn ambient dimension without
backing of the rank too much so what you
do is that you expand your dimension
we're going to a bigger space contents
back and you still preserve them and
again the consequences you just
instantiate it but just the polynomial
based subspace design i showed you and
again it's crucial that is a strong
subfield design then you can get
constant degree dimension expander for
large piece why large feels because the
subspace design only works for lunch
okay so in some sense it meets the the
sort of crude challenge I said of Omega
n dimension substrate is expanding by a
constant factor for large key for small
fields what we can go well we can use
the cyclotomic function field base our
AG based construction but there we have
this s login unfortunately so that means
that the degree has to be basically you
need so this C was not quite constant it
was log in there so now you need login
degree you only get login degree
dimension expanders and this is a bit
harder to explain but you also don't
quite expand dimension Omega M sets you
only expand in over log log n
k which is unfortunate okay so this is
what implication so we get some nice
fairly elementary simple constructions
of dimension expanded but we are
certainly not the first to construct
dimension expander so in fact here here
the pine work was actually better so let
me tell you about the prior work which
actually got better parameters which is
okay and all of these guarantee
expansion four subspaces of dimension up
to Omega n okay so I think I mean it
doesn't ask this question you know in
the around two thousand four or so I
think in response to that lubarsky and
well no no gave a construction and even
had a proposal and they basically proved
that that proposal works for fields of
character of degrees okay so it's based
on something called property tea and it
got constant degree and constant
expansion very good but it only works
for infinity okay and then this was
picked up by in a couple of work so
we'll still car basically gave a
construction which works for all finite
fields but they only got lost degree
expanders for constant expansion or you
can keep the degree constant but the
expansion is Subhan 1 over log in and
they also in this work introduces very
nice notion of molar on expanders which
are basically this notion of vertex
expanders where the edges is the
adjacency max or monotone functions so
it's a very sort of counterintuitive
object but they said that if you have
that then for sort of purely
combinatorial reasons you also get
dimension expansion and they were able
to construct such expanders using a
ceili grasp on the cyclic group and they
got this with us and then we're in
business and said that you can get
better monotone expanders using some
zigzag light construction but what else
but still the degree was in constant and
then in a pretty sophisticated paper
borgen yahoo they have said that you can
actually get constant degree monotone
expanders using expansion in this non
compact group so it is a pretty
difficult paper but one thing about
these monotone expanders have been
fascinating notion but they're a bit of
their very hard because other than just
result there is no other proof of even
existence of these monotone expanders
with constantly so so I won't tell you
formally what these are but basically my
view of these things is that it is
reducing the dimension expansion
problems were pretty difficult
not about the vertex expansion and in
contrast our construction works
completely in the linear algebraic
setting and it's in our belief I can
speak for Michael as well that somehow
dimension expansion should be easier
than vertex expansion so maybe we should
directly attack the problem here rather
than go through that you can imagine
it's funny to get some more electronics
delivered for everything there was for
every field because this boogie near
they are constructed for every fit in
fact the coefficient of the map that m0
deficit 01 map in the matrix of 01 it
was for a week speak and I mean the
reduction is also very simple it just
works but um you know you talk about
rank by some sort of upper triangle type
structure so you just reduce rank for
some combinatorial structures which is
why the monotonicity help all right so
okay so one couple of other things i'm
almost at the end so one thing is it has
I believe not been studied is the
trade-off between expansion and the
degree so as I said earlier if you have
D linear Maps the probability
construction will allow you to expand
the dimension by almost a factor of D
and that this trade-off is probably
quite for in monotone expander based
work just judging by the complexity of
the worse way to those caught me of this
our construction at least you can
quantify what we do we can expand by a
factor of about square root even our
degrees d and that Travis comes because
the tensioning step gains an expansion
alpha by with alpha maps and in the
second strip you have shrink by a factor
of alpha and that also takes about alpha
maps so it seems you compose these
things you get about alpha square map
for expansion of alpha so that's the
trail okay so which is not you know far
from the best but at least something so
a very nice challenges can one actually
achieve dimension expansion which is
linear than the degree or perhaps even
lossless expansion which is well studied
into vertex expansion case and it
expands with 1 minus epsilon time okay I
believe these are not addressed and
perhaps new ideas are required or maybe
our construction can be analyzed better
instead of decomposing it in two parts
and we can make some
ok so just last couple of slides so
that's all I'm say about diamonds and
expanded but it turns out there are some
other pseudo random objects you can
define and these are also worth studying
and connected to subspace design so
probably it's interesting because crowd
so let me mention this notion of a to
source rank condenser which we again
define and it's like it I found you know
I think it's a natural object the
audience motivation for this was to ask
some sort of a recursive approach to
construct substrate the basis that
hasn't quite fanned out but i think the
object is interesting in expand so what
is the to source condenser so you like a
bilinear map from x to the n cross F to
the N 2 X to the M such that for any
role low-rank steps a and B if you take
a cross B and you see what s does to
those things that man should be much
bigger ok so this is the set of size you
know for any text with ranch at most of
this should be cricket what's the two
things you can ask for was the most you
can ask for us the last just multiplies
right because of course you could take a
and B to be linearly independent set of
size are so then this has only size r
square so you cannot expand more than
this all the last week is you give a
little fashion point nine so these are
two things you can ask okay there's a
family it has a very nice d
randomization flavor because what is the
trivial map which will achieve last
let's expand tional like this I mean I
call this condensing because you will
see in a second I want em to be small
but if you didn't care about then you
could just take s to be the tensor
product and this is of course the last
list right and you don't even need to
put any bound on our but I suppose it
has n was very big n with n square so
some of the idea is Dean analyze this
tensor product make em a bit smaller
while still preserving this sort of rank
expansion at least 40 ronxes that's the
challenge and in some sense of loss will
escape as actually quite well understood
it turns out so here is a lemma which we
produce a bit surprising close but it's
an elementary equivalence is that
suppose you have a bi linear map it's a
lossless condensed
four lines are it's only if basically
these maps define right which record of
distance at least our platform okay so
basically the kernel of these maps the
intersection of the colonel shouldn't
have any low line matrix so it's a
linear ranks with a code of large
distance and this is very at least for
finite fields this is an optimal
construction based on analog of
reed-solomon codes that he replaced low
degree polynomials with low linearize
degree polynomials and everything just
works so this is very well understood
and the best end you can get the output
is n times R so you can map things to
intro n square you can map it to mr and
that's the best you can hope for and
that's that you can also use our
approach to get match that and here in
stencil then condemns it's our closest
thing so you want to the problem with
the tensor product is very expensive
with square sticker so what you do first
is that you condense both of these
sources independently which have a
condensing subspace design math you can
use the dimension then you apply the
tensor product I won't get into
parameter but if you do that and all
that you get something a little bit
bigger but then you can stare at it and
say there are some linear dependence is
you can prove that said you can also get
this enough so for lossless things are
well understood the last thing and say
what about lossy kids then say you can
do the point 1 times products of the
ranks so here again you do the random by
linear map it will say that it will work
as long as Emerson at least n plus we'll
ask for a sort of trivial because you
want output trying to be point nine a
square so at least for lower the
bottleneck is you can hope for em to be
order n so the question is can you get
order ok so that's the challenge so the
challenge is for smaller are can you get
a lossy to source the multiple hace 2
4th ranked condenser without put length
linear in them so we don't quite know
how to do that explicitly we can again
try your contents then tensor approach
right nowhere be in the condensing step
we are lossy but unfortunately that
we're not able to get any benefit that
also only gives you they're not so this
is a nice question which would be nice
time ok so is another pseudo random
object seems to be connected to the web
of objects
when we can try to get okay starting at
land on time so again to summarize is
sort of a theory of pseudo random
objects dealing with rank of subspaces
and so on so and substrates design was
one such object which seems to be a
useful construct which connects up many
of these different objects and the
original motivation came from in coding
theory and in fact the construction
curiously enough was actually based on
very similar polynomial code which
actually inspired their definition in
the first place so a lot of connections
with scoring TD well so that's the thing
and there are many open questions as we
can imagine that these objects are sort
of relatively newly defined and none of
them are ever truly optimally
construction technology for improvement
so for fast paced designs you know we
haven't quite resolved it for small
fields so constructing good subspace
designs or small fields without that log
in log n penalty in the intersection Val
will give you also dimension expanders
in a clean simple way for all fees in
the last thing I mentioned for two sorts
condenses you can try to construct them
explicitly and one thing I didn't talk
about in this park is this notion of
subspace evasive set which is another
pseudo random object it's a large set
such that for any low dimensional
subspace very few points lie in that low
dimensional ok so this is also something
we proposed in motivated by lips
decoding and later win and lower edge
gave a construction but the intersection
bound sizes have exponential dependence
in the dimension so they are also
getting close to the random construction
is wide open and if somebody wants to
know the definition of that i can tell
you offline
[Applause]
the construction you subscribe here just
a single variable you do yeah
multivariate polynomial oh well yes sir
norman the function feels best things is
multivariate polynomials but you don't
evaluate mean it's not but I mentioned
to one because it's on a client come up
yeah I don't know it seems pretty you
know somehow it seems like a one memory
object so we have this function field
based construction so as polynomials
they are multivariate but yeah but still
some sort of one-dimensional object
something yeah i don't know like Molly
very amusing present ominously get
better parameters and you want
dimensional stuff because we go is you
know very well be that you can say
there's a finite number but once you
start talking about a lot of material is
hard to say that like there's a small
number grows on two polynomials bae
systems your thumb member too but if you
have no common factors know that the
lake is pleading only has one last year
that's why was the ball so you can
imagine defining to ron skins and the
intersection meaning that both of them
vanish or something sure means but we
don't know but that will be interesting
[Applause]